when you're black you're punk-rock all
the time and that is a sound of punk
short fast riffs lyrics pushing back
against the mainstream mundane the
original don't give a attitude and a no
rules allow genre for self identifying
misfits that emerged at a time where
music was becoming maybe I'm a little
too clean
but Punk's or at least his I saw growing
up rarely look like anything other than
these guys hey guys I'm Sanne
this is aj+ and today we're gonna
explore the very black history and
present of punk music now there was a
decent amount of women who led the
movement Patti Smith Joan Jett Debbie
Harry and Siouxsie Sioux and they all
got major recognition but black or
Latino or any other shade of punk not
really that doesn't sound weird if
you've been taught the history of punk
as something that emerged from the
working-class angst of young white
English men think the Sex Pistols and
the clash but it is weird when you dig a
bit deeper into the history of punk and
find that black and brown Punk's
actually pioneered the movement now the
most popular black American punk band is
probably Bad Brains
of course I want to talk about debt the
guys who helped pioneer Punk without
even trying or knowing
[Music]
[Applause]
death was the three Hackney brothers
from Detroit their music is what's been
called proto-punk Punk before we knew
Punk was Punk
now death broke all the rules there were
three black men playing what was
considered white people's music at a
time where black Americans were known
for playing things like a Motown and
Army you know we felt not to doing it
while we were in our own quarters but
playing it out means that you had to
answer so many questions yeah we totally
spoke to death now the Hackney brothers
did start off by playing like R&B in
fact their band was originally called
rock fire funk Express but by 1973 they
started playing rock'n'roll but we were
just playing hard drive in rock'n'roll
man we were just really trying to be
like a group to the day that we love
like the mc5 and Alice Cooper and all
those great rock-and-roll bands of the
70s we really you know just kind of you
know springboard and all for the sound
that they was laying down but we were
just doing it harder faster and louder
despite their loss sound and unique an
intimidating name which by the way was
totally ahead of its time they didn't
last long as a band they just didn't get
the distribution that they needed with
some record labels worried about how to
market their name and their sound and so
death kind of disbanded but the brothers
continued making music and it was only
30 years later in 2008 that death was
rediscovered and thrown onto people's
radar now even though death didn't go
mainstream their music was known
underground and by the Lowe's diehard
punk fans meaning they had influence it
really was no scene or community or
culture to embrace them and so only
kinda in retrospect that people have
realized like wow these these guys were
making punk rock out of their own inner
creative compulsives in Detroit now
while death is a pioneering band in Punk
history they actually don't necessarily
see what they were doing at the time as
Punk
in fact just plain old rock and roll
we've never really considered ourselves
a punk band I mean back then if you call
somebody a punk you know you got into a
fight we would plan what we conceived
this hard drive in Detroit rock and roll
man it's also important to note as
writer and musician Greg Tate told me
the difference in how white and black
musicians in the same genre will market
it and how that
impact on who got the credit and who got
the fame the American music business is
made up of gatekeepers on the corporate
side on the radio side they very much
subscribed to the Jim Crow notions of
racial separation and segregation which
define American culture throughout you
know most of the 20th century admit that
black artists you know historically for
most of the 20th century couldn't make
its much money playing their own music
didn't have access to the same audiences
you know the same opportunities now in
the 70s there was another black punk
band that really changed the scene Bad
Brains considered one of the most
influential punk bands ever the group
formed in 1976 in Washington DC getting
its name from a Ramones song the punk
man dominated in the 80s with her mix of
reggae and a very aggressive punk sound
known as hardcore in fact they along
with Minor Threat and Black Flag are
considered the pioneers of hardcore
which is a genre of punk which is well
pretty damn fast and DC was hardcores
mecca and also one of the most long-term
influential punk scenes and there were
also other black punk bands like pure
hell fishbone and the UK's x-ray Spex
whose lead vocalist was a woman it's
worth noting that these bands weren't
segregated to some black punk category
they influenced other bands and
vice-versa
take reggae for example numerous white
punk bands use reggae and their music in
the UK throughout the 70s inspired by
black punk bands use of it in my
conversation with tape he mentioned how
this idea that rock or punk as a all
white boys club didn't think exists in
the UK black and brown Punk's were
heavily influencing the same under the
Thatcher government there was a lot of
disenfranchisement of you know white
working-class youth you know who were
non racist or anti-racist they kind of
found their voice and their militancy
through the political actions and the
music of the
black in South Asian born classmates you
know and neighbors and just like their
British counterparts American Punk's
were also really influenced by politics
whether US wars in Cambodia and Vietnam
in the 70s or well Ronald Reagan's whole
presidency throughout the 80s but punk
especially black punk isn't a thing of
the past it's still alive budding
cultural movement today I realized that
like not only is rock and roll
something that is native to people like
myself and honey-child but it's it's
almost like my birthright
that's honey-child Coleman and flash'
Jenkins of the punk band trio the 1865
and yes their name is referencing
exactly what you think it's referencing
the 1865 references America in 1865 but
when the Emancipation Proclamation
brought a lot of promise of change for
black Americans except the racists had
other plans soon after your
organizations like the Ku Klux Klan and
other groups who weren't really fans of
people like myself and this young lady
got together and kind of made it their
business to get in our business and make
it hard for us to to live in America and
so you look at the climate of where we
are now I don't want to necessarily be
so literal but it feels like the same
kinds of sentiments the 1865 makes music
that looks at 1865 America from the lens
of a runaway slave a white southern
soldier a slave owner who felt no guilt
the trio is part of a still growing in
very visible black presence in the punk
scene something that was highlighted in
the 2003 documentary afropunk the
documentary really explored trials and
good times faced by black youth who were
an intimate part of a cultural scene
that has always been seen as white by
outsiders the film ended up inspiring a
bigger cultural movement including a
festival start in 2005 by the same name
the afropunk festival which was started
in Brooklyn and now is international
basically is about celebrating black
artists black creatives and black fans
in the alternative scene honey-child
Coleman Sasha Jenkins and Shana Shanti
who runs a black brown punk festival in
Oakland all say that there's nothing
more
than being black in America I'm not
saying black people created punk-rock
I'm saying we are punk-rock without even
trying the foundations of what people do
that creates punk culture say going on
tour booking your own tour through a
like underground network that's what
black musicians had to do because we
weren't allowed to play in clubs when we
have been pushed to the margins but we
create in those margins and that's like
it doesn't get more punk than that I
knew that it was my legacy and I never I
never believed anyone who told me I was
trying to be white because I love rock
and I love guitars but even though they
all agreed that there's nothing more
Punk than being black they also raise
the point of how different the
experiences of being either white or
black in the punk scene when you're
black your punk rock all the time you're
a target all the time and I can't change
the color of my skin there is a level of
privilege that goes with I'm gonna put a
safety pin through my nose and paint my
hair dye my hair green for three years
and then I'm gonna clean up and put on a
suit and get a corporate job we don't
really have that luxury
you also get credit for having punk
years but in my experience working in
the corporate world
I can't let everybody know what I do
outside of work cuz it cost me my job
and for Shauna it remains
super-important to keep creating spaces
that empower people on the margins I
think it's important to see people who
look like you making music and art it
can feel very isolating and depressing
as a young person when people are trying
to box you into one sort of identity and
tell you how you have to be based on
like your ethnicity or your class Punk
it's complicated even though it's just
simple raw music as a movement it has
this incredibly rich history that like
the people in it is hard to box and if
the black history of punk music tells us
anything it's how instrumental black
musicians have been in the creation of
American pop culture life-changing
interview
and then Sasha especially right hey guys
so we actually filled this piece at 924
Gilman which is the CBGB of the west
coast
if you don't know what CBGB is you
should definitely look that up let us
know what are some of the punk bands
that you grew up listening to and don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
keep it punk